for 50 years
we've relied on schooling as america's
core strategy to promote social and
economic mobility across generations
and build our nation's human capital yet
despite decades of heavy investment
aimed especially to improve the
achievement of disadvantaged children
substantial proportions of lower income
students still
fail to perform at even basic levels in
reading and math
achievement gaps between wealthier and
poorer children remain
huge and here's a big part of the
problem a growing body of science has
established that the crucial foundation
for achievement
in school and beyond is laid in
children's earliest years
long before they enter kindergarten
families are by far the most potent
influence in children's lives
good schools can play an important role
in children's learning and success
but our intense focus on schooling
rather than the non-school environments
that powerfully shape children's
outcomes
is insufficient to accomplish our aims
research tells us that the achievement
gap doesn't originate in schools
a half century of history tells us it
can't be closed by schools
either to learn more about early
childhood
and the achievement gap check the link
in the description below
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from aei